meanwhile barack obama has re-emerged on
the campaign trail because obama wants
his revenge
obama understands that donald trump's
election in 2020 in 2016
was a ringing rebuke of him it was about
hillary but it was also about barack
obama
and there's always been this sort of
bizarro world
reverse polarization between trump and
obama i've told you before
one of my favorite photos in all of
human history is the photo of donald
trump visiting the white house
after being elected and sitting next to
barack obama who has to hand the keys to
this place
to donald trump and it's just obama
looking like he wants to die
while trump gives the trump finger the
drum finger oh yeah
yeah to the cameras and behind him and
behind them
is a bust of abraham lincoln looking at
the floor it is the funniest thing
in the entire world the fact is that all
donald trump is
is the less sophisticated and more
brazen version of barack obama from the
right
right the everything that obama says
about donald trump is true of barack
obama it's one of the great ironies
of american political politics that
barack obama is seen as this
wonderful spokesperson for higher
american ideals when he very obviously
is not so every time you hear obama
speak you should recognize that he's
actually critiquing barack obama he just
doesn't even know it so obama was out on
the campaign trail
for joe biden yesterday in pennsylvania
and he said that you have to stop
tweeting at the television
that doesn't fix things i get that this
president wants full credit for the
economy he inherited
and zero blame for the pandemic that he
ignored
but you know what the job doesn't work
that way
tweeting at the television doesn't fix
things
making stuff up doesn't make people's
lives better
you've got to have a plan you've got to
put in the work
okay um that is a man who never had a
plan and really did not put in
tons of work and when i say he didn't
put in tons of work i'm not saying that
he was lazy i'm saying that he did not
care
about reaching across the aisle and
actually making sure that his proposals
got passed
his idea of work was signing executive
agreement executive orders
pen and phone governance and speaking to
media who just rubbed his ass every
single day i mean that was literally his
idea of the job
also there's a great irony to him
suggesting that it's very bad that trump
tweets about the news
i remember the obama administration okay
i'm not 16 years old i'm 36 so i
remember the entirety of the obama
administration
barack obama found out about half the
things that happened inside his
administration
on the news obama said that hillary
clinton using a non-official system to
conduct government business he said i
found out about that through
news reports he said that he found out
about the va wait time scandal
on the news he said he found out about
the irs targeting conservative groups
on the news he said that he found out
about the doj issuing subpoenas for the
associated press phone records on the
news he said he found out about fast and
furious
on the news he said he found out about
the air force one flyover
over new york city for a photo op he
said he found out about that on the news
right barack obama was an observer to
his own administration according to
barack obama and now he's angry that
trump acts exactly the same way
barack obama broke all the precedents
donald trump was just the guy who
stomped all over them and ground them
into glass
and glass shards i mean he's just into
sand
okay same thing so barack obama went
after trump's language he said he
emboldens others to be cruel and
divisive
well again i'm old enough to remember
the obama administration when it became
stuck in trade to suggest that your
political opponents were bitter clingers
who were evil nasty racist that people
as milk toast as mitt romney were evil
if you want to talk about people
emboldening the cruel and the divisive
barack obama was was no wilting lily in
that particular department here's obama
going after trump
why would we expect and ex
accept this from the president of the
united states
and how why are folks making excuses for
that oh
well that's just that's just him no it's
no there are consequences
to these actions they embolden other
people
to be cruel and divisive
and racist oh okay so um when you were
suggesting that police officers around
the country were systemically racist
that that didn't embolden anyone
nobody when you went to a dallas
police memorial after a bunch of
officers were shot and talked about
american police being bad
that didn't embolden anyone it turns out
every
criticism that barack obama makes about
trump is also true of barack obama
he said that trump can't take the job
seriously now listen
i think a lot of this is true about
trump by the way i think trump doesn't
take the job particularly seriously i
think trump does act like he is
outside his own administration a lot i
think the trump's rhetoric
is very often bad i also think that the
world didn't begin spinning when donald
trump became president and the reason
you ended up with trump is because of
barack obama in maine
here here is barack obama saying that
trump can't take the job seriously this
one president i'll do an interview with
glozell
i have to appear on between two ferns
i'm gonna do a selfie stick
picture of myself in the oval office
this is the same barack obama who spent
a huge chunk of his presidency
hobnobbing with various celebrities
captain seriousness over here i never
thought
donald trump would embrace my vision
or continue my policies but i did hope
for the sake of the country that he
might show
some interest in taking the job
seriously
but it hasn't happened that dude
gasoline he hasn't shown any interest in
doing the work
i'm sorry he's just helping anybody but
himself and his friends i mean
barack obama including the president
he's so irritating he's so irritating
because the media gaslet
the country for eight long years he
gasled the country for eight long years
and he's still gaslighting the country
he was the apex of seriousness as a
human being he was just the most serious
he was the most considerate the most
thoughtful the man who was the most
in-depth in terms of his knowledge the
most bipartisan
the most scandal-free okay if you
believe any of that you're an idiot
none of it was true but we were told all
of it was true and therefore you're
supposed to just listen
and believe my favorite part of obama's
little campaign stump speech
on behalf of joe biden yesterday a
couple things that were my favorites
so he uh he was talking about how there
was a report in the new york times that
donald trump has a corporation
that paid taxes in china because
apparently this corporation
was seeking to build a hotel in china at
one point and barack obama says
that that's a crazy story that right
there that's a bad story i mean if i had
a bank account in china
they'd call me beijing barry that's what
they call me by israeli barry okay first
of all
if anyone called him barry during his
entire presidency they were immediately
labeled racist because his name is
barack not barry even though he called
himself barry back in high school
number two the media would never call
him anything
anything they wouldn't call him late to
dinner
i mean like come on here's barack obama
proclaiming that he was a victim
of media excesses which is oh my god
we know that he continues to do business
with china
because he's got a secret chinese bank
account
how is that possible how is that
possible
a secret chinese bank account listen can
you imagine if i
had a secret chinese bank account when i
was running for re-election
do you think fox news might have been a
little concerned about that
they would have called me beijing barry
okay so um
i'm glad that barack obama's having a
fun time on the stump uh barack obama
did receive campaign contributions in
2008 from foreign sources
he later had to return them barack obama
when it comes to foreign influence
he did promise the russians flexibility
on an open mic in his 2012 re-election
campaign and we were
we were told by the media that it was a
complete nothing burger
barack obama in 2008 there was a tape of
rasheed khalidi who's a spokesperson for
the palestine liberation organization
like an actual terrorist organization
speaking warmly about barack obama that
tape was
obtained by the la times they never
released it yeah but he was a victim of
the media
surely yeah you're right donald trump is
getting a uh he's getting easy treatment
by the media here
and then barack obama just lies to top
all of it off he says that trump messed
up the economy now this is just a lie i
mean there's just an overt falsehood
donald trump likes to claim he built
this economy
but america created 1.5 million more
jobs in the last three years the obama
biden administration than in the first
three years
of the trump pence administration how
you figure that
and that was before he could blame the
pandemic he did
inherit the longest streak of job growth
in american history
but just like everything else he
inherited he messed it up okay
coveted messed it up i mean it's just a
lie
the assumption that the american people
are too stupid to remember six months
ago
or 10 months ago is insane but maybe
maybe he's right maybe he's right
did you know that every like on this
video creates one additional leftist
tier don't ask me why that's called
science to take advantage of this
amazing opportunity hit the like button